yes thank you that's much better
so so natasha people got to be able to
see the baby jesus
baby yeah
good afternoon everyone my name is keith
ellison i'm the attorney general of the
state of minnesota
and since the investigation and
prosecution of this case began last may
everyone involved has pursued one goal
justice we pursued justice wherever it
led
when i became the lead prosecutor for
the case i
asked for time and patience to review
the facts
gather evidence and prosecute for the
murder of george floyd to the fullest
extent
the law allowed i want to thank the
community
for giving us that time and allowing us
to do
our work that long hard painstaking work
has culminated today
i would not call today's verdict justice
however
because justice implies true restoration
but it is accountability
which is the first step towards justice
and now the cause of justice
is in your hands and when i say your
hands i mean the hands of the people of
the united states
george floyd mattered he was loved by
his family and his friends
his death shocked the conscience of our
community our
country the whole world he was loved by
his family and friends
but that isn't why he mattered he
mattered because
he was a human being and there is no way
we can turn away from that reality
the people who stopped and raised their
voices on may 25th
2020 were a bouquet of humanity
a phrase i stole from my friend jerry
blackwell
a bouquet of humanity old young
men and women black and white
a man from the neighborhood just walking
to get a drink
a child going to buy a snack with her
cousin
an off-duty firefighter on her way to a
community garden
brave young women teenagers who press
record on their cell phones
why did they stop they didn't know
george floyd
they didn't know he had a beautiful
family they didn't know
he had been a great athlete and they
didn't know he was a proud father
or that he had people in his life who
loved him
they stopped and raised their voices and
they even challenged authority because
they saw his
humanity they stopped and they raised
their voices because they knew
that what they were seeing was wrong
they didn't need to be medical
professionals or
experts in the use of force they knew it
was wrong
and they were right these community
members this bouquet of humanity
did it again in this trial
they performed simple yet profound
acts of courage they told the truth
and they told the whole world the truth
about what they saw
they were vindicated by the chief of
police
by minneapolis's longest serving police
officer
and by many other police officers who
stepped up and testified
as to what they saw into what they knew
what happened on that street was wrong
we owe it and we owe our gratitude to
fulfilling their we owe them our
gratitude for fulfilling their civic
duty
and for their courage and telling the
truth to countless people in minnesota
and across the united states who join
them in peacefully demanding justice for
george floyd
we say all of us thank you
in the coming days more may seek to
express themselves again
through petition and demonstration i
urge
everyone to honor the legacy of george
floyd by doing so calmly
legally and peacefully i urge everyone
to continue
the journey to transformation and
justice
it's in your hands now i also want to
address the floyd family if i may
over the last year the family of george
floyd had to relive again
and again the worst day of their lives
when they lost their brother their
father their friend
i'm profoundly grateful to them for
giving us the time we needed
to prosecute this case they have shown
the world what grace
in class and courage really look like
although a verdict alone cannot end
their pain
i hope it's another step on the long
path toward healing for them
there's no replacing your beloved perry
or
floyd as his friends called him
but he is the one who sparked a
worldwide movement
and that's important we owe our thanks
to the men and women
of the jury who gave many hours of their
time and
attention to carefully listening to the
evidence
weighing the facts rendering a verdict
they are regular people from all walks
of life
a lot like that bouquet of kim of
humanity
on that corner on may 25th and in that
courtroom
they answered the call and they served
in a landmark trial
they now deserve to return to their
lives
if they ask you to respect their privacy
we
ask you to honor that request
i want to acknowledge the remarkable
team that helped us prosecute the case
we put everything we had into this
prosecution
we presented the best case that we could
and the jury heard us and we're grateful
for that
we had the sole burden of proof in the
case
and history shows that winning cases
like these
can be difficult i'm proud of every hour
every minute and every ounce of effort
we put in this case
and let me tell you we spent many hours
working on this case did we not we week
after week committee meeting after
committee meeting this team
never let up and it never quit we fought
every day
and we did it together the attorney
general's office together with
the hennepin county attorney's office
thank you sir
and we did it together i'm deeply
grateful to everyone who worked on the
case
most of these folks will tell you it's a
bad idea to put together a team of
all michael jordans nobody would want to
pass the ball
this team that was their true strength
is sharing the load passing the ball
understanding that all of us
together are smarter than any one of us
alone
and that works although the verdict
has been rendered this is not the end
in the coming weeks the court will
determine sentencing and later this
summer
we expect to present another case we
will not be talking about that
this verdict reminds us how hard it is
to make enduring change and i just want
to finish by sharing
some important historical legacy if you
allow me
in 1968 the current commission was
formed to investigate
the causes of uprisings across major
american cities
and a man named dr kenneth clark a
famous african-american psychologist
who along with his equally accomplished
psychologist wife
manny contributed to compelling research
in the brown versus board of education
case
and dr clark testified at the kerner
commission and i want to quote you what
he said
i read that report the one in the 1919
riot in chicago and it was if i were
reading the report of investigating the
committee
of the harlem riot in 1935
the report on investigating the harlem
in 1943
and the report of the macomb commission
on the watts riot
i must say again in candor
to you the members of this commission
it's like a
kind of a alice in wonderland with the
same moving picture
re-shown over and over again the same
analysis
the same recommendation and the same in
action those are the words of dr clark
in 1968
here we are in 1920 excuse me
2020 2021
here we are in 2021 still addressing the
same problem
since dr clark testified we have seen
rodney king admiral wema oscar grant
eric garner michael brown freddie gray
sandra bland
philando castile laquan mcdonald stefan
clark
atiana jefferson anton black brianna
taylor
and now dante wright and adam toledo
this has to end we need
true justice that's not one case
that is a social transformation that
says that nobody's beneath the law and
no one is above it
this verdict reminds us that we must
make enduring
systemic societal change
more than a month ago months before
george floyd was murdered
the minnesota public safety commissioner
john harrington and i
released the recommendations of our
working group on reducing deadly force
encounters with law enforcement
what all of us in that working group
including law enforcement
wanted is for everyone to go home safe
anytime someone doesn't everyone's lives
are changed forever
we use this verdict as inflection point
what if we just prevented the problem
instead of having to try these cases
we don't want any more community members
dying at the hands
of law enforcement and their families
lives ruined
we want we don't want any more law
enforcement members having to face
criminal charges
in their family's lives ruin we don't
want any more communities torn apart
one way to prevent this is to get
into a new relationship where we as a
society re-examine the use of force
and our old subtle assumptions i'm so
proud
of chief aerodondo and the minneapolis
police officers who by their testimony
said
enough is enough and another way to
prevent it is by acknowledging and
lifting up everyone's humanity
helping communities heal and officers be
well another way to prevent it is with
accountability
passing laws and instituting policies
and training is important
but they must be more than words on
paper and there must be accountability
for violating them with this verdict we
have brought some accountability
finally this verdict demands us to never
give up the hope
that we can make enduring change
generations of people said
slavery would never end generations said
jim crow would never end
generations said women would never be
equal to men
generations said if you were different
in any way you could never be a full
and equal member of our society today
we have to end this travesty of
recurring endurant
enduring uh deaths at the hands of law
enforcement
those beliefs uh
are things we have to focus our
attention on and as i now do close
i just want to say to you the work of
our generation is to put
unaccountable law enforcement behind us
it's time to transfer the relationship
transform the relationship
between community and the people who are
sworn uh
to protect them from one that is
mistrustful suspicious
and in some cases terrifying into one
that is empathetic
compassionate and affirming with that
benefit
that will benefit everyone including
police officers
who deserve to serve in a profession
that is honored
in departments where they don't have to
worry about
colleagues who don't follow the rules
now the word that work is in your hands
the work of our generation is to put an
end to the vestiges
of jim crow in the centuries of trauma
and finally put an end
to racism we can end it it doesn't have
to be with us
into the future if we decide now
to have true liberty and justice for all
the work of our generation is to say
goodbye to old practices
that don't serve us anymore and to put
them all behind us
one conviction even one like this one
that creates
even one like this one can create a
powerful new opening to shed old
practices
and reset relationships
so with that i just want to say that
i do hope that people step forward
and understand that nobody can do
everything but everybody can do
something
you can do something the way like
everyday people like donald williams and
geneva
genevieve hanson and christopher martin
and charles mcmillan and all those
teenagers and young people
stepped up and did something you can do
things like
help pass the george floyd
justice and accountability act it's in
your hands
let's get the work done and now i'd like
to invite my friend
and partner in justice michael freeman
kennedy county attorney
thank you mr attorney general first
i want once again to extend my heartfelt
sympathies to the families of george
floyd
i hope today's a verdict provide some
measure of closure
for them now let me say what a
tremendous job
attorney general keith ellison did in
recruiting and organizing a talented
team
of prosecutors and supporting staff
great job
matt frank jerry blackwell steve
fletcher and aaron eldridge were
exceptional
their use of experts evidence and
witnesses left
the jury no alternative but to find mr
shavin guilty we and the people of
minnesota
should rightly be proud of these four
and your entire staff of volunteers and
assistant attorney generals and the jobs
they did
over the last seven weeks
i'm also proud from the moment that the
county attorney's office
charged derek children with murder and
manslaughter four days
after george floyd's murder our team
worked long hours
side by side with the attorney general's
team
managing attorney gene burdorff did
legal analysis and writing
assistant hennepin county attorney
joshua larson
did witness prep and strategy
development and vernon boswell
manager of our victim services division
has been in direct contact
for nearly a year now with the family of
george floyd
victim and witness advocates jessica
emmerman
and keith johnson managed all the
witnesses
civilian and professional my two
deputies
lolita yola and andy lefevre and i
supplied strategic advice and
coordination to this talented team
24 7. these guilty verdicts against mr
chavin
cannot be the end of the conversation
about
officer killings of civilians we need to
prevent these killings in the first
place
the minnesota legislature as it moves
into the final three weeks of the
session
must pass a number of bills that will
make policing fairer
and safer for all but especially for
black men and women
and other people of color i've been
lobbying legislators to pass these
critical bills
if they fail then it will be time once
again to have a statewide task force
to hold hearings and come up with model
legislation
intending to put an end to these deaths
i am prepared to be part of that fight
again keith
great shot thank you mike and now i'd
like to
ask the trial lawyers to to share some
thoughts if they have any
uh but before i do that i'd like to
myself
thank uh a number of people and i'm just
gonna start by
and uh well why don't you just why don't
we just uh
why don't we just have uh our trial
lawyers come forward and then we'll
thank our whole team
so uh jerry steve which one do y'all
want to do
thank you attorney general ellison
uh and when i say thank you to attorney
general ellison i want to thank you
for calling me and calling me back into
public service
which is something that i was able to do
as a
federal prosecutor as a state prosecutor
as an assistant county attorney
in the united states army when i left
private practice i thought those days
were behind me but i received a call
and it was from from keith ellison and
he gave me the opportunity to step back
into public service something that is so
important to me
something that i cherish and i would
just encourage
anyone if you get a call like that as an
attorney it's such a
it's a it's a privileged life it's a
noble profession
and if somebody calls you and they ask
you for help
don't overthink it uh just do it as
i've found in my career you you get a
lot
more than you give i'm honored to have
stood with the floyd family just stood
with the state of minnesota
soda as we as we go through this painful
process together
and it's been my privilege to practice
with this
incredible incredible gifted trial team
and so i stand here today in gratitude
i'm thankful i want to thank the jury
for their service
for doing what was right and decent
and correct and speaking the truth and
finding
the right verdict in this case
i'm jerry blackwell and my comments are
going to be
fairly brief i want to first say thank
you
to all of these selfless servants that
you see standing here and the many more
that you do not see
who had the willingness the courage the
passion
the intestinal fortitude to get into
good trouble
they stepped into the light and they
shine
and for that i say thank you i'm
grateful for them i'm grateful for the
opportunity
that i've had to serve now no verdict
can bring george
perry floyd back to us but this verdict
does
give a message to his family that he was
somebody
that his life mattered that all of our
lives
matter and that's important
and i also hope that this verdict for
all of the rest of the collective
all of us will help us further along the
road toward a better
humanity thank you all matt frank
well i can't really follow that too much
but i just want to say that
it's been really a privilege to work
with this awesome group of dedicated
hard-working
people in this endeavor um
but it's also been a just a total
privilege to get to know the floyd
family
and spend time and get them
because first and foremost this is for
you george
and for your family and friends thank
you
thank you
so let me also think very publicly aaron
eldridge who was part of our trial team
who's not here today
but was indispensable lola velasquez
agaloo thank you lola
for a wonderful job that you did josh
larson
josh thanks so much my friend uh zuri
obamakum thank you sorry
and natasha robinson i want to thank you
and for the next generation
the next generation of justice seekers
dion dodd i want to thank you dion where
are you
thank you very much and i want to thank
you for nona boswell
you are a star uh and i also want to
thank so many other people
but for with that we're going to close
our comments right now
and just say that uh we're prepared to
continue to pursue justice
thank you what kind of sentence are you
going to see
hey the deputies are here to escort you
the exits are clear right now
see you guys the uh